voilà trois petites filles de jean
hubert carcy le 27 septembre
basilio adriana karembeu ils sont les
invités ce soir une scène d'anthologie
c'est le soir de la soir de la rencontre
là quand vous dansez dans la boîte c'est
c'est génial fait ça très bien dire que
j'étais sa sous d'autres villes merci
pour le compliment j'ai aussi entraîner
un tout petit peu c'est vrai que la
scène est assez cool on voit pas c'est
bien jean loup voulais juste injustement
vous montrez là mais regarde vers un
verre par là on va pas calmer une scène
très bien aussi parce que ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que vous vous envoyer plein
de mecs dans le film donc les trois
petites elles pensent que vous êtes une
[ __ ] écuissés votre mac est en fait un
soir sur la plage vous re expliquer que
non c'est parce que vous aimez ça c'est
un peu comme les bonbons quoi mangeuse
d'armes
ouais mais qu'en plus gourmandes comme
les chiens moi je suis copropriétaire
ouais mes parents et même en tant
qu'elle est capable de me pardonner de
m'accepter comme je suis donc tu crois
et une scène d'amour où elle te met les
menottes en fourrure rose qui est très
bien il ya une vision des hommes assez
terrible où on n'en sort pas très grand
dit du film et surtout avec ses gonds
compliments sur vous il a dit c'est une
actrice débutante bien sûr mais c'est
pas un mannequin qui jouent la comédie
réussie c'était difficile de qu'elle
accepte de ça je trouve ça très
courageux parce que c'est vrai que pour
une fois on s'intéresse pas que sa
plastique comme un bleu
dans ses émissions ce n'est pas qu'un
jambon c'est aussi un esprit et une à
une elles parler aux femmes au total la
charcuterie ces faits batignolles dans
copains non mais c'est quelqu'un qui a
une très belle âme est qui et qui est
une actrice débutante mais qui débute
bien écrire beaucoup de sincérité je
pense qu'elle est comme les petites
filles qui sont aussi des impôts
débutants et c'est donc un film
s'appellerait quatre pros petite fille
plus une grande comme christian karembeu
il a accepté facilement que vous fassiez
passé le monde parce que parce que voilà
si ça l'était lhermitte à tilleur est un
caca nerveux
non il m'a presque fou cette affaire
parce que le scénario a plu énormément
bas il a lui aussi ce que ce que j'avais
autant info et puis cela il m'a dit
vas-y essais on va voir qu'est ce que ça
donne ça programme vous partie aussi
longtemps de la maison 45 jours celle
points selon parce que j'ai l'habitude
de travailler travailler est rentré chez
moi chez moi c'est vraiment où je me
repose je respire c'est découvrir ce que
c'est maintenant tous les acteurs ont ce
problème là les mémoires à il est venu
oui c'est déjà beaucoup les parents
contrairement je ne connais pas tu es
sur wii j'entendais parler risquent tous
les haïtiens et christian
et d'asile de ta femme elle te suis en
tournée pour l'instant j'y suis pas en
tournée mais elle va me suivre
elle va suivre toutes les dates tout
peut-être n'ont donc sont haram le petit
là bientôt un garde temps en temps réel
comme moi deux filles et un garçon alors
ouais mais dites moi je dis pas toujours
la vérité voilà sa part michel libye ça
fait six ans vous êtes marié avec
christian à sa neuvième année comme
prenaient ensemble
pour ma part je sais pas été le premier
jour je sens que pour lui aussi
tu vas pas changer quoi non parce que la
première fois que si vous disiez que
vous faisais l'amour trois fois par jour
c'est toujours le cas ici jamais dit ça
à bauchi non deux fois j'ai jamais parlé
de ça une fois non plaît pas trop dur de
rester fidèles quand même sérieux pour
moi ouais pas du tout ah ben oui mais
pas que gérard d'après envie de craquer
en france et on s'est un peu mais on
n'est pas du tout compatible ça marche
partout j'ai pris une petite voiture il
faut acheter un kangoo
jean mineur
le temps